thank you uh yasser yes i'm here with
aryan tari who is a two-time norway
national champion 2015 and 2019
he's also a grand master very good one
at that world junior champion
and the list goes on uh but
he's in a different role here in
bucharest tell us a little bit about uh
that first of all welcome to the show
and tell us a little bit about thanks
christian
um yeah it's a new role here uh first
time actually i'm a second so
it's very interesting for me to try this
i'm just used to
play professionally myself but when
anish asked me to
help him i was just very happy for the
opportunity
because also these days you don't have a
lot of tournaments so i
i wasn't too busy uh so
how is that for you because we know
you've been playing chess for a very
long time but
as a coach or a trainer or a second it's
really different
it's really different the mentality and
so on you when you go to a tournament
you're so used to
a play but when you prepare it's a
completely different
uh experience yeah so you work this
uh long hours in the in the nights and
not so much sleep
but you just do your do your best to so
anish will
do as well as possible tell me a little
bit about the schedule
when do you sleep usually and uh here
it's been like maybe i'm curious to
compare it with mine back when i was uh
uh here it's been four am usually 4 a.m
yeah then i wake up for breakfast at 10.
he's really working you hard uh yeah i'm
just trying trying to do my
my best to to help him yeah very good
you're here for the first time in
bucharest that's right what do you feel
about how do you feel about the city uh
actually we just one day went to explore
the city almira
showed us showed us a lot so that was
very nice but besides that we've been
just walking around the hotel
but on the rest day we saw some nice
buildings we went to a
coffee house we ate in a nice restaurant
so that was really enjoyable very nice
let's get into chess
um let's look at this game between anish
your pupil let's see and uh mvl
what can you tell us about this giveaway
interesting position
like these positions are very similar to
the grundfelds
uh but the thing is usually the pawn is
on e4 in the
in the green field but here it's uh it's
on e3 so so enviol
has been playing this move order this
english move order that's correct and
we'll usually always
place this uh move order nvl is a player
who always plays the same openings
usually he doesn't really change so much
his
repertoire so we did expect this
uh opening today and uh yeah this was
our our preparation
and he actually played uh this mvl that
is against jakob venko if i'm not
mistaken
that's that's correct yeah this queen if
i move uh
i'm pretty sure sure we had it like in
general we we studied these types of
position i think we looked at night we
looked at knight c6 here queen c7
um yeah queen a5 uh
also these types of position we we
looked at but uh
it was a lot of move orders so i'm not
so surprised only
spent some time but in general i think
these positions are a bit easier to play
for white like white has
some more space so what is the general
plan behind the white's
structure like you sometimes go h3 you
try to time e4 after at the right moment
uh and then you then you take take space
maybe you play e5
it really depends you play rook b1
provoke b6 i think this is what we have
on the board
very often you go a4 you put the bishop
to h3 he does a does a good job there
just
uh black can be a bit passive sometimes
and uh
he has to be accurate so i think this
rook b1
provoking b6 also aimed at potentially
placing that bishop on a6 once the
knight goes to
c6 definitely like sometimes uh like
let's say if the rook goes
here or something you might go bish
basics and distract the rook there are a
lot of these
possibilities in some positions
yeah so yeah this bishop can be annoying
sometimes it goes to b5 to distract the
distracted knight
also black always have to think about d
takes c5 so in general i think
objectively speaking black is black is
solid but uh
it's a bit easier to play to play white
so it's it's a risk-free
slight edge i would say absolutely as a
trainer do you feel uh
some of this preparation will translate
into your games as well
we'll see obviously as a second you hope
you can also use it your
yourself so it's uh
so i've also learned from these openings
although my some of these openings i
maybe
usually don't play myself but certainly
i can play them yeah speaking of uh you
playing what is your
next tournament i'm playing the world
cup which
starts pretty soon it's just one month
and if people want to follow you where
they're working they
follow you the world cup sure the world
cup but also
social media and we know the new
generation is pretty big on social media
yeah no i have instagram you can follow
me on instagram it's just
uh just my name our antare um
and yeah i mean my tournaments they all
go live so you can follow there
but in general my social media i mostly
post on instagram or twitter also i am
but not so active
there you have it thank you very much
for joining us and good luck in your
preparation thank you thank you guys
back to you